[Music]
traveling is something we all like to do
many of us use our traditional bicycle
skateboard and car but what if you could
get something a little more inventive
and exciting could you believe that a
futuristic invention from one of the
best science fiction movies is now real
watch our video to find out what it is
if you're new to our channel don't
forget to subscribe and give our video a
big thumbs up get ready to have your
mind blown because today we are going to
show you the 10 coolest means of
transportation in the world electric
unicycle do you live in the countryside
or a rural area your commute to work
must be fabulous however for those of us
that live in overcrowded cities we
aren't so lucky in places like Los
Angeles New York and Beijing driving a
mile on the freeway can take what feels
like forever luckily there are
contraptions out there to help you zip
around a lot faster one of these gizmos
is the $300 T gt3 self-balancing
unicycle this gadget is selling out all
over the world for five main reasons
first they automatically balance
themselves so all you have to do is get
on and go second they are insanely safe
they have passed the quality and safety
testing of the national authoritative
organization this is because of the
accelerometer gyroscope keeps its
balance based upon the weight of the
rider
it even has intelligent speed protection
to help keep you from running into
things third it is light and easy for
even kids to carry forth it has a range
of 11 miles with a 30 minute rapid
recharge TIFF it can reach speeds of 11
miles per hour the only thing that could
make this cooler would be to juggle a
panda while riding in semi submarine for
those who have been on a boat before in
the middle of the ocean
the thought of capsizing may have
crossed your mind once or twice right
well imagine if it didn't matter that
you were setting sail into a storm with
this awesome mode of transportation you
won't have to worry about that anymore
this is the ego compact semi submarine
how can something be a semi submarine
well it is called so because the top
deck never fully submerges the stem
my submarine comes with a whopping price
tag of available upon request that's
right
the price is so outrageous that you're
only able to know it once you go through
the buying process while voyaging you
can either enjoy the Sun and get your
tan on or you can venture into the lower
compartment where you can take in the
sights but don't worry this thing is a
speed monster with two electrical
propulsion horizontal three horsepower
thrusters in a running time of eight
hours all while cruising at whopping
maximum speeds of three knots for those
who don't speak boat that equates to
about three and a half miles per hour
hopefully they have seat belts huh
unicycle motorcycle at the age of 17
been Gulick had a vision which he spent
three years developing the idea shocked
a motorcycle and automotive community
after its unveiling to the world been
his dodge his invention uno the uno has
two wheels side by side designed to
mimic that of the Segway all you do is
hop on keep your balance lean forward
and the bike starts moving the design
makes it easier to turn since each wheel
is completely independent of one another
each wheel also houses its own full
suspension Bend design this by himself
with the help of 3d software he kept the
design small and light so it can be
easily stored indoors and even carried
upstairs the motorcycle is substantially
light
weighing in at 120 pounds the bike can
carry people at a top speed of 15 miles
per hour for hours if that wasn't cool
enough it's also fully electric and
recharges with a regular household
outlet if this ever takes off we're sure
it won't be long before we see a massive
gang of clowns riding this bike down the
street submarine scooter have you ever
wanted to scuba dive in the middle of
the deepest oceans with no protection
covering your body
this next coolest transport is right up
your alley we'd like to introduce you to
the submarine scooter made famous in the
islands of Hawaii the company promises
to take you on a truly unique underwater
adventure aboard one of their
submersible scooters there is no diving
experience required all you have to do
is fly it in one of the
Islands sign up hand them your cash and
set sail for the middle of the ocean
when you reach your dive location you
simply get to the scooter and close the
lid you are then lowered into the ocean
was only an oxygen cord attached to your
scooter now you can cruise the depths of
the sea up to four miles per hour if
you're worried about them polluting the
ocean don't all of these scooters are
electric and emit no emissions Tours
typically lasts between one to two hours
which is more than enough time to take
that selfie you've been dreaming of
let's just help you know sharks try to
photobomb you see through canoe since
the beginning of time people have
traveled across the globe in search of
new and exciting locales from the tops
of mountains to the deep jungles someone
was always curious to discover these new
worlds before planes a majority of these
travels were made by boats crossing
rivers lakes and oceans it was not until
around 1878 the Holman Jones invented
the first glass-bottom boat in none
other than in Silver Spring Florida the
waters surrounding Key West Florida are
absolutely majestic and perfect for such
a boat we don't know whether we should
praise the man for his brilliant
invention or be scared out of our minds
it's already terrifying enough thinking
of jobs sinking a ship but now the shark
can burst right through those panes of
glass okay this might be an exaggeration
but still the revamp version of Homans
invention is the see-through canoe this
new and improved version is also a
product of Florida and is sold in Key
West the see-through canoe has a flat
bottom and is great for beginners it's
said to be very stable and puncture
proof the canoe is made from the same
polycarbonate material used in the
production of bulletproof glass their
motto is built tough not cheap and for
our sakes we hope so light cycle after
watching the 2010 film Tron Legacy most
of us are still swooning over all the
amazing technology but what really makes
those green with envy are the light
cycles how many of us want to drive one
of those around the city at night well
there's good news for us all luckily for
us an inventive and creative duo known
as the Parker Brothers are making our
dreams come true
Marc and Shanon Parker have created the
neutron this amazing futuristic electric
motorcycle was created after the
brothers were inspired by Tron the
Parker Brothers were told that this
motorcycle was unbuildable but they
stayed true to their motto of pushing
boundaries and thinking outside the box
the neutron is definitely something to
see the motorcycle has a 90 fixable
electric motor and a lithium battery
pack it can range about a hundred miles
on a 35 minute charge from its sleek
curves in beautiful detail to the
hubless wheels that make it look like
the bike is floating this ride is
definitely on our wish list the cost
will set you back about $55,000 you
better hurry because there are only 25
made for this year hoverboard Marty
McFly had his wishing for his awesome
hoverboard when he carved through the
town in Back to the Future 2 we waited
eagerly for the technology to catch up
when 2015 hit and we still had no
hoverboards we were pretty disappointed
but now we can renew our hope because
the famous car company Lexus
successfully created a real-life
writeable hoverboard the Lexus
hoverboard has been in development for
18 months
you're probably wondering how it works
right creating the hoverboard required a
lot of innovation creativity and finding
the perfect combination of
superconductors magnets and liquid
nitrogen yes you heard that right
magnets magnets could be a ton of fun
and in this case they can create magic
there are permanent magnets in the board
along with an insulated core in liquid
nitrogen that keeps the board cool the
board is placed on the track that also
contains magnets and helps maintain the
hovering height of the board itself
although currently the board can only
hover about an inch off the ground
we hope Lexus keeps advancing the
technology we can't wait until we start
hovering around like our favorite time
traveler aero-x roads where we are going
we don't need roads
if the famous quote from you guessed it
Back to the Future the creators of our
next coolest transportation had to be
inspired by this film the design of it
also looks like the creators have spent
a little too much time watching and re
watching the Mad Max series here is the
arrow X a creation of arrow facts who
have set out on a mission to democratize
flight for air effects airplanes and
helicopters are expensive and
complicated they're out of reach for
most people their goal is to reduce cost
and simplify piloting the arrow X is a
two-seater
capable of transporting people 10 feet
above the ground
at speeds up to 45 miles per hour
carbon-fiber rotators take the place of
wheels which allows the bike to take off
vertically the design also allows the
arrow acts to be as easy to ride as a
motorcycle the beast weighs over 800
pounds and can carry over 300 pounds on
one tank of gas it will run for 75
minutes
it is built and sold in California and
the price tag for this is over $85,000
watt car have you ever been walking for
a long period of time and wish you had a
bathroom weight scale you could pull out
of your bag place it on the ground and
ride it to your destination yeah neither
of we but apparently 26 year old Cooney
aku Saito and his team at Koko Motors in
Japan have been wishing for this very
thing this team came up with a cool
transportation device the size of a
laptop with wheels that fits in a small
bag
it definitely resembles the bathroom
scale right the device weighs about four
to six and a half pounds depending on
which model you get there is an indoor
model and an outdoor model the watt car
is exactly like the Segway but without
the bulk this small invention can hold a
staggering 265 pounds and is fully
electric it takes right around an hour
to fully charge but can be used for
about an hour at a maximum speed of 10
miles per hour
the rider controls the device by
slightly leaning in the direction they
want to travel once the rider steps off
it stops the price for this easily
portable cool transportation device will
set you back a little more than twelve
hundred dollars post modern skateboard
we live in an era where we are pretty
much only limited by nothing more than
our imagination the world were what was
unbelievable 30 years ago is now
easily a reality with some hard work and
creative mind the next coolest invention
is the coolest of the coolest it might
not propel you over a hundred miles per
hour or let you hover over the ground
and they don't give you the ability to
see the ocean floor as you travel but
they're insanely lightweight Portability
and fun factor score huge points with us
are you ready here it is
the sidewinding circular skates now they
don't look like much but these two rings
are bursting with fun ready for any user
these are compact easy to transport
durable and all-weather proof and for
those of you who have to call an
electrician to screw in a light bulb
they are ridiculously easy to assemble
look at these people as they zip and
zoom through the streets they are
propelled by leaning side to side and
the user moves forward in a serpentine
motion but even though these skates can
go through dirt short grass and turn on
a dime
skitching is definitely something we do
not recommend with these which one of
these amazing rides do you want to try
let us know in the comment section below
if you want to see more awesome videos
like this don't forget to subscribe to
our Channel
thanks for watching
[Music]